hope you guys had a great weekend I I
had a good weekend as you can see I'm
showing off my Ravens pride here a
little bit Ravens had a big big win over
the Denver Broncos and I think after
that performance my Baltimore Ravens are
probably the best team in not only in
the league now but probably the best
team in the history of professional
sports so and then if they if they lose
next week against the Steelers then then
they'll be the worst team in my mind and
that's that's what if you're if you're a
sports fan it's a very bipolar
experience because your team is always
either the best team or the worst team
recently the Ravens have been the worst
team a lot because they've been losing
quite a bit but anyway hope you guys had
a good weekend so let's talk about well
it was clear to any observant person
that the Democrats were stalling last
last week to give themselves more of an
opportunity to conjure up another
accuser against Brett Kavanaugh and all
of the back-and-forth about the
particulars relating to Kristine for
testifying the discussions about who
would go first about how many commit
cameras would be there about who you
know but all that kind of stuff about
whether Kristine Ford should have to fly
because apparently at the last minute
she decided that she's afraid of flying
you know all of that was nothing but a
delay tactic and a transparent delay
tactic to give the Democrats more time
to do what they did last night and what
they did last night is they whipped
together another accusation and guys
this one is even flimsier than the first
one I mean this one makes the first one
seem credible by comparison and I didn't
think the first one was all that
credible in the first place well
actually we have two new accusations
sort of okay so um the first one
Michael avenatti the stormy Daniels
lawyer the creepy porn lawyer as Tucker
Carlson called him he is now claiming
that he is aware of quote significant
evidence that Kavanagh was basically the
ringleader of some kind of like rape
gang that would go around to house
parties in the suburban D
see area in the 80s and they would just
take turns raping women this is what
he's this is what he's now claiming we
should also mention if it wasn't clear
already that Michael avenatti is quite
possibly the scummiest person on the
political scene today and that as you
know I mean that is saying something
he's got a lot of competition for that
title especially in his own party but
even in the other party as well but but
I think that quite possibly is true
now we'll just we're just gonna ignore
his accusations and and move on to the
piece published by The New Yorker
written by Ronan Farrow who is the guy
responsible for a lot of the different
me to reports on you know he's reported
on several high-profile meanto cases and
usually his reporting has been pretty
solid this though this is not solid now
I'm gonna go through some of this New
Yorker article and we will analyze it
together because I want you to if you
haven't read the article I want you to
just get an idea I want you to
understand to kind of see just how
desperate and dishonest the opposition
to Cavanaugh has become because what's
happened to Cavanaugh now this makes
this makes the Robert Bork treatment
look gentle by comparison so we're gonna
have to change the name because you we
used to say that if a if a if a Supreme
Court nominee is destroyed by the other
party we say he got borked well now
we're gonna have to say Cavanaugh even
though Bork you know the last name Bork
makes for a better verb then borked
sounds better than Cavanaugh but this is
this this I think is even worse than
what happened aboard so let me read a
little bit from this piece it says the
woman at the center of the story Debra
Ramirez who is 53 attended Yale with
Cavanaugh where she studied sociology
and psychology later she spent years
working for an organization that
supports victims of domestic violence
The New Yorker contacted Ramirez after
learning of her possible involvement in
an incident involving Cavanaugh the
allegation was also conveyed to
Democratic senators by a
civil rights lawyer for Ramirez the
sudden attention has become has been
unwelcome and prompted difficult choices
she now it's it's it's been reported
elsewhere that she came forward with his
story when Democrats came looking for it
which shouldn't be a surprise they've
been looking for this dirt and so that's
why she's speaking now she was at first
hesitant to speak publicly partly
because her memories contained gaps
because she had been drinking at the
time of the alleged incident and her
initial conversations within the order
she was reluctant to characterize
Cavanaugh's role in the alleged incident
with certainty after six days of
carefully assessing her memories and
consulting with her attorney ramirez
said that she felt confident of her
recollections to say that she remembers
Kavanagh had exposed himself at a
drunken dormitory party party thrust his
penis in her face and caused her to
touch it without her consent as she
pushed him away Ramirez is now calling
for the FBI to investigate Cavanaugh's
were all in the incident now if you
please can we go back and hone in on
this for just a minute where she says in
her initial conversations with The New
Yorker she was reluctant to characterize
Cavanaugh's role in the alleged incident
certainty after six days of carefully
assessing her memories and consulting
with her attorney she then decided that
Kavanagh was the guy so this is a
drunken memory from 35 years ago up
until this week she wasn't sure if
Kavanaugh was involved at all but after
talking to her lawyers for six days and
assessing her memories she decided that
he was
Wow so so what is this is this is like a
repressed memory that her lawyers were
able to bring to the surface
what was it hypnosis I mean how did they
get this memory out of her mind is that
what this was now never mind the fact
that the whole idea of repressed
memories is bogus
but even if because that's you know
that's something that I feel like that
that idea of repressed memories is kind
of plays a part in this in how the
public views the Kavanaugh situation you
know when you hear about a woman who
says this thing happened but she didn't
remember the details until just now and
and then we think well oh yeah let's
like a repressed memory but we're
getting that from TV shows and from
movies in Hollywood in reality that
doesn't actually exist you're not gonna
have someone who was traumatized by an
event but then but doesn't remember and
then all the sudden years later it just
pops to there into their mind because of
some jostling usually from a therapist
but in this case from a lawyer doesn't
really work that way in fact in in in
you know most of the time if somebody is
traumatized not only do they not forget
it but they have the opposite problem
where they replay it in their mind a
hundred times a day for the rest of
their life but that's that's often how
this goes but in this case we're told
well we aren't told that she forgot the
entire incident she remembered it I
guess but she didn't remember who it was
that actually you know did this thing
and until now so I guess that was a
repressed memory so going back to the
article says Ramirez said that when both
she and Cavanaugh were freshmen at Yale
she was invited by a friend on the
women's soccer team to a dorm room party
she recalled that the party took place
in a suite at Lawrence Hall in the part
of Yale known as the old campus and that
a small group of students decided to
play a drinking game together we were
sitting in a court in a circle she said
people would pick who drink Ramirez was
chosen repeatedly she said and quickly
became inebriated at one point she said
a male student pointed a gag a gag
plastic penis in her direction later she
said she was on the floor foggy and
slurring her words as that male student
and another stood by a third male
student then exposed himself to her
quote I remember a penis being in front
of my face she said I knew that's not
what I wanted even in the Steven in that
state of mind she recalled remarking
that's not a real penis and the other
students laughed at her confusion and
and taunting her one encouraging her to
kiss it quote/unquote kiss it she said
that she pushed the person away touching
it in the process
Ramirez who was raised a devout Catholic
and Connecticut said that she was shaken
quote I was I wasn't going to touch a
penis until I was married she said I was
embarrassed and ashamed and humiliated
she remembers Cavanaugh standing to her
right and laughing pulling up his pants
Brett was laughing she said I can still
see his face she recalled another male
students shouting about the incident
somebody yelled down the hall Brett
Kavanaugh just put his penis in Debbie's
face she said quote it was his full name
I don't think it was just Brett and I
remember hearing and being mortified
that this was out there okay and yet
after several days of considering the
matter carefully she said I'm confident
about the pants coming up and I'm
confident about Brett being there okay a
few things to unpack here first of all
the woman said she was lying on the
floor drunk so she's completely wasted
foggy and slurring her words the article
says but notice the passive way that
this is worded she quickly became
inebriated is what it said as if it was
something that just happened you know
outside of her control not a decision
that she made anyway um
second she calls on her a devout
Catholic faith you know as part of this
story yet she also admits that she was
lying on the floor drunk at a party with
a bunch of college boys and look people
get drunk at parties in college I'm not
gonna call her character in a question
for that but it's just you can't really
fall back on the I was just a good
Catholic girl thing given the context I
mean it seems like she added that in as
a way to kind of bolster her credibility
but yet given the context it's just it's
it's hard to make that case
third thing she says she remembers
someone shouting Brett Kavanaugh put his
penis in WC face but then she also has
been saying this whole time
that she wasn't really sure if Kavanaugh
was the one who did this now that
doesn't really make sense because if she
really remembers someone literally
shouting
Brett Kavanaugh did this thing like his
full name then she wouldn't have any
doubts that Brett Kavanaugh did this
thing the fact that she does have doubts
even now it seems would seem to indicate
that this part of the story the part
about the person shouting is must not
have really happened because if she 100%
remembers that that somebody shouted
then she should be 100% confident about
this whole story which she isn't and
then forth the only thing she seems to
be confident about is that the pants
came up and Brett Kavanaugh was there so
in summary she says okay I'm confident
that the pants were coming up and Brett
Kavanaugh was there that's not the same
thing as saying I'm confident that Brett
Kavanaugh was the one okay now we get
really to the crux of the matter here
going back to the article says The New
Yorker has not confirmed with other
eyewitnesses that Cavanaugh was present
at the party the magazine content
contacted several dozen classmates of
Ramirez and Cavanaugh regarding the
incident many did not respond to
interview requests others declined to
comment or said they did not attend or
remember the party a classmate of
Ramirezes who declined to be identified
said that another student told him about
the incident either on the night of the
party or in the next day or two
the classmate said that he is 100% sure
that he was told at the time that
Cavanaugh was a student who expose
himself to Ramirez he independently
recalled many of the same details
offered by Ramirez including that a male
student had encouraged Kavanagh as he
exposed himself the classmate liked
Ramirez recalled that the party took
place in a common room in the first
floor an entryway B of Lawrence Hall
during their freshman year okay so no
eyewitnesses confirm the story some have
disputed it but they did find a
corroborating story from anonymous
person which was relayed secondhand so
this is a person doesn't want to be
identified but they say that someone
told them that this thing happened now
let's look at this statement from the
article it says in a statement two of
those male classmates who Ramirez allege
were involved in the incident and the
wife of a third male student who she
said was involved and three other
classmates disputed Ramirezes accounts
of the event one of them says quote we
were we were the people closest to Brett
Kavanaugh during his first year at Yale
he was a roommate to some of us and we
spent a great deal time with him some of
us were also friends with Deborah
Ramirez during and after her time at
Yale we could say with confidence that
if the incident Debbie alleges ever
occurred we would have seen or heard
about it and we did not the behavior she
describes will be completely out of
character for Brett in addition some of
us knew Debby Debby long after Yale and
she never described this incident until
Brett Supreme Court nomination was
pending and then and then we also hear
from a former friend of Debby Ramirez
who was married to the classmate alleged
to be involved and she says and she said
that look I was best friends with
Ramirez during school and we shared all
these different intimate details of our
lives with each other she never
mentioned this she never said anything
about this okay so there you go
multiple alleged eyewitnesses contradict
her account a friend of Ramirez
contradicts it so again we have no
evidence no corroborating accounts
several contradictory accounts and
somehow the New York earth considered
this fit to print I mean it's it's
remarkable and of course we again ask
ourselves even if this was true which
there's no reason to think it was true
but even if this incident even if this
drunken incident did occur between all
these drunk people at a college party
where Brett Kavanaugh you know pulled
his pants down
does that matter now 35 years later does
it have any bearing on the fact you know
on whether or not he is capable of being
a competent Supreme Court justice and
for this story even more than for the
other one I I say certainly no it
doesn't really have any bearing true or
not and again there's no reason to think
that it is true but sure or not I just
don't see how this has any impact
whatsoever on whether or not he would be
a reliable Supreme Court justice and
it's also heartening now now we're told
I guess that this has traumatized her
that she's you know been traumatized
fort by it for a whole life but that's
kind of hard to believe - I gotta be
honest with you because for one thing up
until this week she didn't even remember
if Brett Kavanaugh was the guy again
that is not it's not generally how it
works if somebody traumatizes you does
something that traumatized you you're
gonna remember them now you may be may
be foggy on some other details but
you're gonna remember who did it and
then we also have this last thing from
the article that I'll read she's Ramirez
said that she continued to socialize
with one of the male classmates who had
egged on Kavanagh during the party she
invited the classmate to her house for
Thanksgiving after he totally had
nowhere to go
she also attended his wedding years
later as a gift guests of his wife and
said that she posed for photographs with
Kavanagh smiling okay but so so again
but so she was supposedly traumatized by
this event yet she was still friends
with at least one of the guys that was
involved for years after the fact never
said anything to about but you know
never mention this story to anybody was
friends with it with this guy and now
all the sudden it's changed the article
also says that Ramirez said that she
remains silent about the matter and did
not fully confront her marek memories
about it for years because she blamed
her
for drinking too much she says even if I
did drink too much any person observing
it would they want their daughter their
granddaughter with a penis in their face
while they're drinking that much she
said I can say that at 53 but when I was
19 or 20 I was a vulnerable I didn't
know any better
reflecting on the incident now she says
she considers Cavanaugh's male
classmates culpable they're accountable
for not stopping this she said however
what Brett did is the worse she added
what does it mean that this person has a
role in defining women's rights in our
future okay so two last things first of
all she gives away her political
motivations with that last line yeah you
know he's gonna have a role in defining
women's rights so obviously this is a
pro-abortion person she's a registered
Democrat so this is this is she at least
is partially politically motivated which
could explain how you know that that
could have factored into this Sun
epiphany that she's had this past week
about the fact that Brett Kavanaugh was
was involved in in her mind she thinks
that Brett Kavanaugh is a threat to her
to her very human rights as a woman
which he's not but that's what she
thinks so it seems like she would have a
very powerful subconscious motivation at
least subconscious motivation to put
Brett Cavanaugh's face on to this
situation even if he wasn't involved but
the second thing is you know and this
doesn't really matter but you see how
she takes absolutely no responsibility
for the fact that she got wasted at the
party she says I didn't know any better
well okay well can Bret calves and I'll
use that excuse I mean look the whole
thing is is is kind of a joke at this
point what Republicans need to do is
they just need to confirm Brett
Kavanaugh and be done with this they
need to grow a spine and say you know
what we're done well we're not doing
this anymore we are not going to just
sit here and wait while the
Kratts go around trying to dig up
whatever skeletons or imagine the
skeletons they can find so they can
parade them in front of the media we're
not gonna sit around waiting for them to
do that we're not gonna give them
another week or two weeks to to go and
see if they can find even more accusers
and even more accusations from drunken
parties 35 years ago that's what the
Republicans should say we're not gonna
do that we're just going to confirm him
and if you don't like it too bad that's
all
Supreme Court is not an elected position
so Brett Kavanaugh doesn't need to be
popular it honestly doesn't matter what
you how people feel about it that's what
the Republicans need to say but they
won't say because they're cowards so
this spectacle will only continue until
Brett Kavanaugh until the Republicans
develop enough of a spine to finally put
an end to it which I don't know if
that's going to happen we'll leave it
there thanks for watching everybody
thanks for listening Godspeed